[Musique]
alors
Michel Sardou fait donc référence au
baril de Sandrine Rousseau qui serait un
homme déconstruit fait référence à ce
qui avait déclaré la député notamment
lors des primaires des verres en 2022 en
parlant de son mariage regardez je vous
reprends une des phrases que vous avez
prononcées je ne fais pas confiance
aujourd'hui à des personnes politiques
en l'occurrence des hommes qui n'ont pas
déconstruits qui n'ont pas traversé
d'événements qui les ont déstabilisés
dans leur vie pour mener ce qu'on a
amené pour le dire autrement l'écologie
c'est pas des hommes blancs à vélo dans
les villes la déconstruction c'est une
affaire qui à un moment donné nécessite
de de passer du temps qui demande une
forme de volonté aussi de déconstruire
les a priori que nous pouvons chacun
avoir et ça et bien elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas évidemment mis sur chacune de
ces différences évidemment que non moi
par exemple je me vis avec un homme
déconstruit et j'en suis hyper heureuse
par exemple alors et Sandrine Rousseau
elle lui a répondu lors de la
manifestation hier contre la réforme des
retraites elle a posté un petit message
assez explicite on la voit poser devant
une pas très clair regardez voilà donc
c'est pas les cafés la pancarte mais
voilà elle a elle a elle a posté ça
alors j'ai vu que par exemple il y a mon
ami Bruno Pommard qui lui a dit que
c'était inadmissible qu'elle fasse ça
qu'une élue façade sous vous en pensez
gilberté moi je suis pour Sandrine
Rousseau dans cette affaire hein je
trouve que la riposte est exactement
proportionnée à l'attaque il lui a non
c'est l'enfer pour lui dire elle elle
est vulgaire lui il a été correcte non
c'est pas s'il y a l'ironie là-dedans
c'est le ta gueule excusez-moi ici sur
ce plateau parfois on s'interrompt
fortement et il peut m'arriver ben la
montée le meilleur ta gueule voilà et ça
paraît pas une insulte rédhibitoire
voilà donc de mon point de vue de mon
point de vue il y a égalité entre les
deux voilà
c'était intéressant
c'est pas une de mes meilleurs polémique
autour d'elle n'a pas lieu d'être
Delphine je suis hyper d'accord avec
Gilles et parce que une femme sera plus
heureuse si elle est avec un homme
déconstruit dans le sens où il faut
arrêter d'être dans ce principe du
patriarcat et où les hommes ne font
absolument rien et restent dans leur
région
Michel Sardou
là on se positionne sur la forme sur la
forme Michel Sardou il a plutôt été sur
le boutade et du monstres avec beaucoup
de degrés et elle lui répond mais
attention c'est une élu de la République
et une élu de la République qui
s'appelle ta gueule c'est plus gênant
elle aurait pu avoir un discours et lui
répondre sur une d'une autre façon mais
c'est ça en fait et donc il y a deux
choses qui sont tout à fait opposées un
artiste qui sur le mode de la boutade va
aller chercher une élue et une élue qui
répond quasiment
elle répond pas vraiment elle ta gueule
c'est une pancarte c'est pour ces propos
sur la grève qu'on va revoir il a pas
hésité à prendre position sur d'autres
sujets d'actualité il a notamment donné
son avis sur la grève d'hier et je pense
que c'était une réponse voilà c'est
c'est pas son émission qui avait
dans la manif oui
sur la grève regardez moi je suis un peu
contre cette main libre non pas sur le
fond ce que je pense qu'il y a une
incompréhension entre peuple français et
le gouvernement français mais je suis
contre le fait de
paralyser la France de bloquer voilà ça
c'est pas utile en ce moment enfin c'est
mon idée je suis pas politicien je m'en
fous je me présente à rien moi mais
paralyser la France en ce moment après
avoir
subit
le covid le machin les gilets jaunes que
c'est ça va avec paralysie plus risque
de baston et de violences
voilà alors là dessus je trouve que
Sardou moi il n'a pas à dire ça je suis
désolé il n'a pas à dire comme ça c'est
pas bien de paralyser le pays ça veut
dire il faut pas manifester en filigrane
et moi ça me choque il dit ça mais
excusez-moi
vous comprenez rien là franchement
Gilles vous le faites exprès
c'est votre heure c'est votre allez-y
il n'a pas dit était bouchée de partout
toi tu n'as pas dit qu'il était contre
la manif il dit exactement non il a pas
dit que il a dit simplement que il
trouve ça dommage si c'est le pays est
bloqué il a pas dit qu'il est contre la
manif donc il est pour ce qui s'est
passé
comment tu peux dire le alors vous aussi
n'existe
comme vous la veille la veille de la
manif dire je suis contre le fait
paralysé et j'ai peur des violences
c'est pas une manière de dire je ne veux
pas
j'aurais que Nicolas perdicoff nous
donne moi je vous comprends pas
c'est-à-dire que un moment donné vous
refusez le débat c'est une émission de
débat il est libre il a une liberté
d'expression Sardou il a toujours eu sur
le front national ou sur d'autres choses
qu'est-ce qui dit aujourd'hui on lui
pose une question un journaliste lui
pose une question par rapport par
rapport à ça il répond tout simplement
qu'il trouve ça nul pour les Français
parce que on s'est pris le covid qu'on
s'est pris plein de choses mais il n'a
plus le droit de s'exprimer si mais elle
a le droit de s'exprimer aussi et du
coup mais il ne l'attaque il nous
l'attaque aucunement mais elle continue
de la République dire un artiste Sardou
ta gueule je trouve qu'elle devrait
démissionner juste poster en dessous de
la pancarte on la connaît spécialiste et
c'est une opportuniste elle passe son
temps en permanence pour exister
rebondir sur les trucs en politique
pardon mais pour l'instant je l'ai vu
aucun exemple d'une loi qui est la
défendu et qu'elle a le mené jusqu'au
bout
toujours parler de disruption et de
parler effectivement de destruction de
l'homme et autre chose
destruquement en fait à l'homme de
revenir en arrière de réfléchir de faire
une une introspection et accepter machin
mais je veux dire à un moment c'est de
l'intelligence j'en ai rien à de
Sandrine je connaissais juste son père
par la Compagnie Créole mais c'est pas
grave
non moi j'apprécie beaucoup Michel
Sardou et c'est un des rares mec qui a
le courage de dire vraiment ce qu'il
pense il y a plein de gens qui pensent
comme lui et puis qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas sur le fond au moins lui il y a du
fond elle a même si j'ai compris que la
pancarte c'était pour les retraites
c'est quand une manière de lui dire ta
gueule suite à ses propos et là il y a
aucun fond donc sa place Sandrine
Rousseau elle est pas sur BFM TV elle
est dans les Marseillais elle n'a aucun
foin elle veut faire du mal c'est la
vérité
que ça Michel Sardou il a du fond et il
ose dire ce que plein de gens pensent
c'est insupportable ces histoires de
Walking de déconstruction ça va c'est
bon alors tiens bah là tu es réveillé
Delphine hein
pas du tout pas du tout mais je veux
dire si Michel Sardou est envie de
parler d'une politique sur sa politique
c'est une chose mais là il parle du
couple qu'il a qu'elle a avec son mari
et elle dit le pauvre mari elle doit pas
être facile et tout en fait
ces oignons mais en fait c'est pas ses
oignons
et donc elle répond c'est bon que tout
le monde veut pécho on le sait pour toi
un homme déconstruit c'est pour ça ça
nous intéresse de savoir qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un homme déconstruit que tu
souhaites non mais c'est le partage des
tâches et c'est pas et c'est pas l'homme
au-dessus de la femme et en fait
ce que lui ce que ça veut dire oui mais
c'est pas ça il a dit il a dit ouais
enfin bon moi passer l'aspirateur
moi et moi non plus j'ai pas de problème
elles ont super envie de passer la
caméra
[Applaudissements]
elle aime bien le faire elle aime bien
que le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alors avant la famille oh là là
parfois quand je vais pour prendre
l'aspirateur dit non chérie laisse-moi
le faire
il fait la cuisine je fais la cuisine
J'adore cuisiner ah oui j'adore ça je
fais très très bien les autres le matin